- Triforce
hi hi Peter yeah I was rehearsing it all
morning
mm-hmm yeah cool
hey everyone its Triforce I'm Peter
Browns Rob Hilary we're gonna play of
Legend of Zelda breath of the while
because we can't get enough of it we're
continuing to just play through master
mode we're gonna tackle master Koga
today it's very much known as the most
difficult boss in Zelda have you seen
the reddit threads on how to beat him
it's like 500 pages took me like 20
times and that was just on regular so
we're doing on master peter master mode
I don't know I don't think we can do it
probably not probably not but that's why
you know that's why we're here that's
what the Triforce is hope that's how my
god put us on this verdant earth yeah so
this is you know Thursday's livestream
GameSpot has a live stream every day at
11 a.m. except for the weekends so thank
you for joining us let's get to the game
let's go kick kogas ass Peter turn your
mic up says GameSpot turn my mic up it
sounds good to me can you hear me better
now oh sorry I was just taking photos
man so hot alright so how's your time in
master mode been because you've been
playing for bits
I haven't played for a bit yeah it's
been pretty good uh you know it's funny
I'm still avoiding enemies despite like
having the Majora's Mask you know the
other day we're talking about like oh
you know most enemies will ignore you
but what I was realizing when I said the
other day when I was like oh there's I
felt like I was higher level guys like
caught on and like attack me eventually
what really happens is if stalls are out
or if choo-choos or like other types of
enemies that are not fazed by your mask
yeah skeleton yeah then they then it's a
party and everyone wants yes those are
so easy to be though they're just as
easy as the regular mode right but like
you can just be you know in a camp maybe
thinking you're all good with a mask and
and a couple of those jelly flood heads
pop up jelly bellies jelly bellies but
yeah it's all good but I'm still having
fun man that's cool I really like this
game I was telling you the other day
like still finding different areas how
many hours into
I don't like I try to tell right like
you know you playing every day oh sure
yeah I took a little bit of break a few
days but I've been really focusing on
shrines yeah and I was gonna say
unfortunately I could well the first
things I would recommend doing is
getting all the towers just to get it
over with
and I have not gone the Gerudo tower so
we gotta do that first
yeah I think it's it's there that's okay
that's that's part of the journey and
the other thing I have been noticing
that I actually really like is it was
that did Sora's domain and do this and
you know like the series of waterfalls
you need to go up was a brown wooden
chest could have been that great a chest
is a chest anyway what I was getting at
was like it's neat to see those those
lifts that we just passed yeah they're
placed in really cool areas like going
up the waterfall there's like so many so
you go up like the the biggest waterfall
and Zoras domain and then you can then
jump down and like it's just like a
bunch of steps and platforms like all
around the waterfall that makes sense
it's like cool placement of those things
like it's not just you know
I've had hazard Li just like placed
anywhere like they they kind of thought
about it and the enemy types are
different I do like those lifts I was
kind of skeptical when they first
mentioned it but they're definitely like
orchestrated you know the new enemy
layouts yeah it can't just be it could
be random but it doesn't seem that way
to me yeah I think I made a boo-boo
Rob I don't know where does a dam tower
is why do you need the tower why can't
she do you need the tower to get into
the canyon well just to get at the start
of you clan hideout
oh it's right here isn't there oh this
is it yeah it's I mean it's in the
desert it's along the cliffs it's on the
southwest side we can do it regardless
Mike dumb ass is going wrong way Rob
someone in the chat says it's really
weird to see you because their name is
also Rob but their last name is similar
Oh what is it yeah what is your last
name Rob 1610 when AOL first came out my
screen name was Rob hand it's a hot
snatch do you want to know am ia Wall
Street knows the the flank part of my
stories I had a lot of people there's
apparently a guy in North Carolina named
Rob hand yeah and so I was getting all
of his buddies hitting me up on a I am
like non-stop and he he like hit me up
and he said he was like really
frustrated I think the same thing was
happened to him it was like all
lowercase for him or some [ __ ] no no I
got what Pete Brown damn just my name we
were in the beta for he oh well I still
have Pete Brown at aol.com email address
and if I still used a my would be on
there
and like you I got contacted by people
that I didn't know one was a prison
inmate we thought I was his buddy on the
outside and wrote some fucked-up [ __ ] to
me the other one was this woman who
thought I was part of her family and
they had a child but that was like on
it's on their deathbed basically oh no I
was getting like every couple days a new
update and it was so sad and I even
emailed her and I was like I'm not who
you think I am
it pains me to see these emails I'm
really sorry you're rolling through but
just so you know you're sending them to
a stranger and yeah and I just kept
getting emails never responded to my
yeah it's my plea to just break me free
of that cycle
seriously dang your story is a more
heartbreaking than mine I'm all about
heartbreaking stories I feel like my mic
is still low know what's going on and
the other thing about master mode is
having played so much with like Rivoli's
Gayle and stuff yeah you kind of forget
that you can't do a lot of the stuff
that you would like to do for instance I
think I'm kind of digging myself a
little bit of a ditch here I dug myself
a ditch by telling people they can reach
me at Pete Brown a ol doc which I never
checked so I'll never see your emails
speech like this was a bad idea already
I guess that's what's neat is like kind
of going back master Modi being like man
this is a tough world to travel in yeah
that was like the that was the challenge
right it was just sort of like getting
to where you want it to go without dying
along the way and you'd only die because
you couldn't go the path you wanted to
and had to face challenges that were on
the path you could take yeah excellent
balance and I'm worried I'm worried I
think you can do it yeah I put on that
stuff it's like the hardest part about
this well master go-go will be very
difficult but the hardest part is
getting there
apparently my mic is loud because I'm a
little hard-ass yes but we need that no
they're saying compared to you I may be
sound quiet I should turn your done
I'm very loud people in this office do
not like me that's not true
I think so we all tolerate you but yeah
like this Armour phantom Armour has been
clutch this more so Aires mask
I'll keep this gear actually sub-games
lover thanks for joining the chats we
are on our way to the Iggy clan we're
gonna do the little stealth mission
which I don't master cogez side when I
was doing the stealth mission I was like
racking my brain because okay I could
get anywhere inside of their hideout but
I couldn't find the thing I was looking
for yeah I eventually bought that The
Dude's enough that I got good enough to
beat them even though they were really
difficult they were I mean by the time
he faced those guys at least when I did
like one or two hits from them was dead
yeah and I couldn't I couldn't beat it
and I was like so frustrated I don't
remember how I figured it out I think
maybe it was like an accident I was like
flipping through my powers like
activated it and then I found that wall
and it was just like are you kidding me
this has been in front of me the entire
time
it didn't even like it was clever but I
didn't even think it was clever I was
just pissed off that that's what it was
yeah wasting hours of my life yeah that
I had a tough time with that for sure
it was very centered on self which was
kind of neat but I liked I mastered that
part you know what I mean it was then it
was just like I don't know what I'm
supposed to do in here like what how
like what is where's the thing I'm
looking for right anyway
yeah I'm excited to see it again to be
honest and playing on master mode with
not many hearts yeah I've been investing
in stamina just because I think it's
crucial yeah I mean that is the thing
right like will they notice you from
further away in master mode which would
make stuff a lot more difficult yeah I'm
just gonna get a little bit G no
checkpoint here I remember when we first
started playing this game I was like on
the first things I said to you and
you're like totally which is like
shrines are cool but my god those names
go in one like you're out the other like
I just you just forget them so quickly
oh yeah
just fine it's neat it's the sheikah the
sheep go away oh I came back do you ever
like come back here and look at all
these I know just kind of like hop
around these platforms and lyft's
there's a lot try to yeah yeah I really
like following the rivers in this game I
can follow along the coast you'll you'll
just bump into a lot of cool little
things yeah
I'd like to get up there but you might
be able to pull it off nice little lift
here I mean the step one is believing
yourself I love it step two is have
enough standing but faith is really you
know the most important part yeah the
other day I think I know if I saw it
somewhere and read it but if check
confirm if you wear like metal armor or
gear does that make you louder like I
feel like it does all right
it's I mean logic would say yeah but I
don't know if the game does that right
family guys wondering how long is a
stream typically about 90 minutes I
think that'll be the case today will
probably go until 12:30 Pacific but we
will be beating master code I mean if we
can if we can you what else you playing
lately Rob well you can't quite talk
about it right now but stay tuned Monday
for a game that you and I've been
playing I don't know what else I can say
yeah I'm playing I'm really excited for
titanfall next week I think it's gonna
be I think this is the first few updates
were kind of subpar for titanfall free
updates if you will sure and they've
been kind of ramping up the last one was
great this next one I think is gonna be
the biggest cuz it's got four player
co-op which I think will bring back
people who maybe I don't know
intimidated by the multiplayer because
it can be frustrating I think I think
multiplayer for titanfall is doesn't
have the best matchmaking system like as
far as putting you against people
appropriate skill levels and sprite like
it
it goes back and forth but it's a it's a
cool ass mode it looks really neat
oh they want to play Oh wasn't there a
design can they talk about a design
decision to like not let you walk on to
the wildlife like wolves just to make it
more challenging or something like that
that's interesting yeah okay again there
where the sneak armor at a karaoke
village that you love it and I think
that's pretty important armor definitely
for the earlier person's game all right
it's not okay it's not what I thought it
was like in the canyon it is this is
definitely it the start of it run you
have to get there this is on the way to
the entrance of a different King yeah
that's kind of done to ditch my horse I
took a warpath I didn't want to say
anything
Wow what else are you playing Peter uh
Super Metroid the last week I'm
recording a podcast with a buddy of mine
Kevin Larry be back in my play it's like
a podcast doing for a few years um it's
a lot of fun Super Metroid he's great as
always that game I am I tend not to play
it very often like I'd put years between
playthroughs which allows me to always
be taken back by just how tightly
composed it is you have great atmosphere
solid mechanics looks great sounds great
but it's just the pacing of what you
unlock and how you get to boss fights in
new areas it's really good like you're
never really unless you get stuck
somewhere you're never really left doing
anything that feels like filler in my
opinion it's one of you know the few
like perfect games like that damn
perfect you know is not to be taken
literally but it's one of those games
were sort of like yeah I wouldn't really
change anything about it there you go
gube is asking about Castlevania there's
a lot of good Castlevania games the the
best ones to play in my opinion would be
Symphony of the Night super Castlevania
4s 2003 is pretty good it's a little bit
stiff by today's standards as is the
original Castlevania but if you like
three play the original as well rob is
doing great there are a bunch of
Castlevania games on des that are all
pretty good I believe John of sorrow is
the best one it's been a while I forget
I wouldn't about this it's easier to
name Castlevania is to avoid don't play
to don't play legacy of Darkness or the
other one on 64 don't play Castlevania
judgment the we fighting game do not
play
I don't know lords of shadow is a good
game lords of Shadow - that's good I
think okay I think I reviewed I
definitely review the second one I don't
think I reviewed the first one but
looking back I think I would play the
first one over the second again and even
mirror of fate on 3ds made by mercury
steam the company that I made the
console games and is working on Metroid
Samus returns late 30s they made a
pretty decent like Metroidvania ish
Castlevania on 3ds that has some
QuickTime events which are weird and
it's got its fair share of problems but
cool little story and decent little
gameplay so there's a lot of a lot of
good Castlevania games out there for
sure there you have it yeah coop says I
was not ready for that great you hang in
there Emilio in with the tip of a hat
just like what's your favorite area in
Zelda Peter and mrs. Alda yeah let me
count the areas I don't know maybe no
it's probably that like tropical cult oh
no tropical yeah yeah yeah yeah that
town was there's nothing to do there
there is not I did the gambling thing
there yeah it was I yeah but just like I
guess maybe it's cuz when I found it - I
was like okay I've seen everything in
this game I'm towards the end wait a
minute what the hell is that and it was
just like a little like vacation
paradise yeah I don't know man there's a
lot of really good places in this game
obviously I think mine would be fair and
fair on barren forest
it's like that really rain force II area
yeah
despite the frequent thunderstorms and
rain storms I really like that area it's
just like really beautiful Rob 1610 if
you're gonna play one Castlevania
definitely played a symphony of the
night we can play it on PlayStation
PlayStation 3 PSP Vita it's not on ps4
unfortunately but it's out there and
it's best Castlevania game oh there's
this Oh try climb this well now I have
to go home to go up there and then yeah
put your dog on a leash Oh what okay put
your dog on a leash
[Laughter]
I don't know would that be too
time-consuming you think to play
Castlevania hahaha this tower I don't
know is that your closest landmark
outside of a saved game I mean I can
save game anywhere I want but it's a
little smart like you do it we're close
don't do it
screw it you blew it I should have done
this earlier
it's fine it's a nice build up right
you're gonna end on a epic boss fight
there it is Oh
the Dragons through the Dragons are
still so cool to come across yeah I just
wish I could ride one yeah definitely
cannot cast apparently cast that much
Michael I I don't I don't understand why
everyone was like oh my god guys are so
cool I gotta agree with you he was kind
of stuck up well you didn't do much for
me like he always had like the same
story I felt like to tell like the song
was the same every time yeah was it not
cool all these little bows on this thing
very second I thought you look at all
these lasagnas brands back-pay brand
back again but no Kass the song that he
sings it's the same no matter where you
meet him right right he needs to change
it up I'm just uh
where does he change it based on the
location cuz I thought like when he's
like oh he'll tell me they'll sing me
different songs but then I remember like
I think listening to one like the second
location I found him and I was like I am
pretty sure I've heard this song before
and seen these little you know still
animation cutscene things he's probably
all in the same key yeah but but even
like the images he was showing me I was
like I've definitely seen like I don't
know yeah I'd love some confirmation on
that I guess I could just open the game
and figure it out for myself but he's uh
my favorite character I saw people like
art scene like comments like oh he's the
best character in game yeah no I think
master master kuba is my favorite Koga
he's pretty good he's pretty awesome
like when I first played that I it was a
non-stop grin throughout that entire
battle that to our battle
I don't need a cool-down Bob I'm sure
damn bowlers we're getting there
god I wish I had those sand boots oh
yeah like his face when he's like don't
you marry it yeah I'm good what's your
favorite armor um I'm a big fan of the
ninja mask and then let's see for the
top you know once I got it I kind of
like the male Gerudo armor look like the
shoulder piece oh yeah link snip hanging
out I really like the climbing here whoa
[Music]
weird you know well really hates me he's
engineering because engineering is right
outside this door and when I hear John
Luke say yeah we hear you and he's all
the way down across the room they
probably all go out to lunch now if your
engineering makes a lot more than us so
they can they can deal with it those
guys are great dan you've you
engineering folks that are watching yeah
look at this this Peter okay Thomas
Vincent says it is the same song I was
right what am I looking at Sam SANNs
what you know what line I think is
definitely played out is the Anakin
Skywalker stand line it's like I see it
all the time
I don't like sad
it's coarse rough it gets everywhere
anyways I remember that line but I've
never really I don't think is oh it
begins
these guys are bananas don't really have
too great of an arsenal right now I
don't want to say anything but you've
been holding back a lot huh yeah
German Buland loves your beard Peter oh
thank you it's a nice beard I can't grow
a beard I my beard trimmer broke and
I've been meaning to go get one
he's like a you know like a buzzer and I
use like scissors oh but I haven't
gotten a new one
it's my beard is it kind of doing its
own thing and my neck is a mess right
now I think I've got kind of hair that
was like two feet long wrapped up in my
beer did you see my brother's beard oh
really so my brother's beard is like
eight inches below his chin but it's not
just like a long beard it's thick you
couldn't you could lose your keys in
that thing and never get them back it's
ridiculous
and they wear stuff to put weed in there
man but I don't smoke what sweetie
seriously though it's dang it's
ridiculous I don't know I would never
want a beard like that and he's also
he's also taken to wearing sunglasses
all the time so he's always got Ray Bans
and a massive beard he's like a he's
like a hipster ZZ Top guy but with a
gang or better be
those guys were kind of a mess yeah they
were sure loved classic cars and rock
and roll what's that pose they always do
like like that one music video yeah like
long legs she's got legs anyways you
ever noticed that the Geeta clan they're
so they're so bad that they take like
the chicest sign it is flip it up flip
it upside down yeah all right
how are you ever going to get in there
better safe how do I get the Guardian
sword um I think I got them in those
tests of strength shrines so you can go
is go back to so once there's a blood
mood and you can always go back there
and loot those guys because they'll
spawn they drop all the pressure I got
all the stuff in them yeah you can also
take items from guardians and then take
them up to the laboratory the Northeast
and trade those in and get some Guardian
gear wait Peter rebelled oh how do I
guess you need to quest to get in there
don't you drop in I don't want it I
don't know don't don't do this to me I
think you might have to climb up there
and drop in
goddamnit yeah via caller tech lab
that's it I don't like this I don't like
this I gotta do its magnet I don't think
it's magnetic know that you're Bob I
think you're thinking of the wall inside
the hideout it's up Julio Peter I don't
like this hey man like life is full of
things we don't like you know what do
you do you pick up the pieces you move
on I do need the quest he taught me he
had a right answer before so maybe he's
right I do need the quest
this sucks you're not far you're not far
I don't know if a tea Shaw has get nap
but he says put an arrow in those eyes
on those DAGs oh that's right you need
to dress as a weight jeans dress is a
vibe to get into the hideout or just to
get into Gerudo village I was I don't
remember it maybe there's less another
way it's great so have you been to
Gerudo at all
I think you have to think you have to
complete like mini quests for yeah cuz
there's that character on the top now on
the roof right who's like oh you need
female clothing to get in there I can
get you some female clothing but you
need to do these things for me
just joining us we are idiots I am no no
no one's an idiot here you blew it
Brandon says well okay we done forgot a
key step and that thing we wanted to do
it's just been so long Peter described
to me how long he's been it's been
probably it's very hard
don't 300 hours since I last played that
yeah I saw those I bet shrine yeah oh I
could have worked back there that's dumb
whatever I'll get a sand seal would be
good mistakes are still being made Rob
did you goof where did you do that as a
goof
there's an important distinction to be
made there yeah I'm I'm a goof so you
goofed it wasn't done as a goof on us I
goofed intentionally or you goofed us
gotcha
Gupta goofed yeah got you guys have you
ever seen the ten that movie I'm
referencing do you like the dudes from
the state and hot what America what how
to marry absolutely so the ten is this
movie they made about the ten
commandments and it's all these little
like short vignettes that it basically
extended skits and I believe there's
like this one skit where this guy ends
up in prison and the whole thing he
didn't screw up he did it on purpose as
a joke but everyone is confused over him
goofing before having goofed that's the
premise for the entire thing yeah I
killed the guy but it was a goof there
you go thank you goob you know what I'm
talking about so I need to go to this
was a called bizarre saw buck that's our
town and I think there's that's where I
buy the
what I
bizarre-o I don't even know the name of
it what is it is it when I close
remotely close to is just another
mispronunciation I just don't remember
the name of the town if I thought can
you remember how its spell yes I
mispronounce the whole time
there's there's two A's in this form of
bizarre so the way that you pronounce it
almost minutes no David Wayne was not
the one who did the goofing I don't
think wasn't it wasn't it's the guy who
had the afro and one how to amend summer
the short shorts I never actually got
laid
or was it David Wain okay David Wain is
awesome
do you ever watch his webseries dude
he's got a whole web series there like
dozens of episodes that started years
ago I don't know if it's still going
it's called Wayne Edie's yeah it's
pretty good
oh this is close to pneumatic that won't
know again we will never repeat Zach
wetter we were trying to make up for
that which we have failed to do which is
to prepare for what we need to do to get
into and hide out goop shoo Raya did not
start on Stella
or do you mean the goof joke started on
stone
[Music]
and these conversations need to be more
immediate Imperial walkers
[Music]
[Music]
I like goofin someone's submission to
the shrine the guy next to shrine
I'm pretty sure I I can get the stuff
here right oh I thought you the fit is
here isn't it
got you goob you you get something here
you have to like get stuff from here and
bring it back to the person who wears
peanut clothes hi sock
but I go back to that shrine man I'm
moving hard it's goofed in my pants what
is this I don't know read unless chat
knows exactly GUP in yeah I was born to
goof oh boy all right
I cannot remember so I go back that's
right yeah top of the store building
that makes sense is there a big ladder
there you're saying the I oh yeah yeah
the guy near the closer I got near the
shrine as well I feel like that guy sell
it just sells you stand boots or
whatever nope no oh it might be have to
be during the day oh no okay yeah that
guy gotcha
GUP in USA welcome to goof country USA
yeah anyone tuning in right now is
probably very confused as to why we keep
saying goof and what we're doing when
we're because we're not doing what we
said we were gonna do well
this is Triforce and we wanted to fight
master Koga the egit clan we got there
and whoops we didn't do the requisite
stuff to actually get into it so we're
just goofing around
having goofed Ken Marino that's the
freaking name Oh a different guy okay
I'm trusting Thomas here in the chat
fairy effects
say own it hmm have you been playing
these all that lately a little bit yeah
I started masking it again but then once
I got the the mask Majora's Mask I kind
of felt like crap I think I screwed this
for myself
mm-hmm because I had a lot of fun like
playing and being like super focused in
the face of like regular enemies and
like avoiding them and stuff and then
once I got the mask it was like [ __ ] I
just stripped away a lot of the
difficulty and I could choose not to
wear it but just knowing that I have
that option it took a little bit the
steam at the wind out of my sails yeah I
mean I am switching back and forth Oh
God so I showed this earlier goofin it
so this dude he's just walking around I
guess so I think if you travel between
here and Bazar town
no there is that guy that guy is the
sand boots guy I know that much you
don't mind cause he just circles the
place excuse me
yeah yeah yeah
do you think we're gonna get a new mr.
Mintz in the game I don't know [ __ ] them
he's shy lady oh it is this guy ah dang
I'm looking for women's clothing I'm in
search of Pentos well how they dive back
into the sand man now I better if cool
thanks do you think we're gonna get like
a sweet new environment in the next deal
see and they said that you know they
said dungeon it's confirmed to be a
prequel right uh I mean yeah like it
goes back in time a bit but I'm yeah I'm
curious like are we gonna be then just
replaying the same areas of Hyrule that
made me look a little bit different or
are we gonna get entirely new areas he's
got a white beard
this part was awesome
is deep good thing you've got enough
yeah how'd you get that many rupees oh
you know mining uh-huh oh yeah so it's
just one outfit you don't to get like
different pieces what
oh my gosh you saw nothing sounds great
mining soldier armor yeah whatever I
can't remember right soldier armor I
don't think is that cool-looking Wow
yeah I think I said before reminds me of
like when Sam and Frodo wear orc armor
Return of the King
that's the Phantom armor the offensive
armor is a whole different story so then
if I talk to the the princess right yes
[Music]
all the kids in each town are so funny
yo I need my helmet go get my helmet for
me oh hello
[Music]
yet another traveler how did you get in
here
can we skip this well I saw a cool post
on like I don't know if you know the the
lore of Gerudo but it's like every
hundred years of males born go on I all
meet with him what I don't know how the
process works
no no remember you've seen like the the
dating classes like in Gerudo town right
it's like a classroom with like here's
what a man is here is how to date with a
man right well that's like yeah I mean
obviously they like can go out and like
get a husband but I think book but
there's something about what's what's
the divine or the champion for Gerudo
what's-her-name I forgot she said it but
she like mentioned Gannon and like how
he was a disgrace to their their
people's like he was like I think the
last yeah I think or one of them I don't
want to alarm you but Guy Fieri does
join the chat
Guy Fieri Zelda fan get out of here
scamp
did I get it now oh we're close
did he ask nope I'm good no one ever
says hi to me like that same I'll say
how do you like that
[Music]
hmm got those ABS here we go Peter
Robert I think when I put up this vaad
I'm just gonna cut to here hi guys
welcome to try 40 we are about to tackle
the master koopa coca cuca and it's a
good thing we prepared because this was
actually a surprisingly long journey to
get to this point but don't worry you
guys don't have to endure that on the
Strand right oh wait no I'm sorry we
press screwed up and we took us 45
minutes to get to everyone Peter I know
wait to start again hi Simon Simon he
says hi my name is Simon by the way did
you know my name is Simon and I like to
do drawings are you looking at my ass
cheeky bum you're not sunbathing dude
you're getting me back I mean I just had
it on with you over this game I don't
know
I sent them my mixtape - yeah yeah oh
you know that you can rent a faster San
Cielo but you also have to kind of go
through the whole process what is it
like a race thing or something I don't
think you've to win the race to rent
them
well renting is one thing I don't know
if you get faster ones after recently I
don't know what I'm talking about it's
been too long since I've done this don't
listen to me
[Music]
Ben and rook
one of us snowboarding didn't you go
snowboarding just like a month ago I did
it you know what I also did is I filmed
a bit of I got a Hylian Shield Hylian
Shield excuse me and was gonna film or I
did film a like on a high eight camera a
snowboarding guide on top of a mountain
in Tahoe
I don't know I haven't come around don't
like blowing up the footage the Hat
because the thing is I haven't done it
so long looks like an SD card some
digital I like you know you just toss in
a computer like forgot how to like
basically capture off a camera like that
whole process like the capturing to tape
or ever it is yeah it's funny how like
much more tedious process it is yep
linear editing knowledge we had to like
make trailers from the existing movie
which meant like splicing together an
already edited thing to do any of that
tape to tape Edit Bay [ __ ] yes some of
it not much I don't believe I only had
to do it for one semester it is sort of
like the intro they're like we're gonna
show you how we don't do things anymore
so you appreciate all the tools we have
now like okay fine I did yeah I took a
film course all the way from senior year
to last year at college
wouldn't your last year be your senior
year from high school and then Oh
it's on Peter Brown who owe me yes
thanks for opening it up guys time we
don't get there this might take us a
really long time we gonna get there
I don't did you sneak in this part yeah
they like do a good job of introducing
the idea of okay here's the stealth part
right you have to figure out which one
of these doorways is the right one to
continue oh man I totally forgot about
this Harry got a boyo hmm just shoot him
at all of them
it's not that one there might be some
goodies in there yeah no there was
nothing to burn any other other was yeah
I wonder when the DLC will come out like
exactly when holiday you know I'm gonna
say December 11th December 11th I'm just
doing this because I hate the Eagle in
burning all oh no my bows are fire
burnin all y'all ban is you know I also
just realized after you do this you're
out of arrows
no I got bunny Yuka clan guys will come
more often or the bigger guys at least
right Rhett you're late
well this here take what you're doing it
I'm new I'm doing I'm playing like I
would write myself alone in a room yeah
yeah all right okay all right greevey
teased a nanner manner banana why are
you in here just get out idiot
I got escaped somehow well well start by
getting up oh I'll never see them do is
patrol any bananas in red there's a clue
here I can't see they seem to like burn
there no sorry I'm doing it again no
arrows I need that all right it's on
great
it's first-year huh
this guy's in he's walkin around that
thing in the middle right so you gotta
get ready to toss some bananas or I'm
gonna bring out my big guns here yeah
this will do he's gonna kill you in one
hit really yeah
should I use my temporary hearts no dude
he's gonna I mean dude if you want but
he's doing these dudes are really strong
yeah let's drop some of these favorite I
mean you could for all I know you could
be really good you could Parry and dodge
a lot of stuff like without fail but I
think if you mess up at all especially a
master and you get like you reset from
each area I can't remember how far back
back to the beginning every single time
really yeah tight to the basically where
the little jail cell was Joey and ever
talk about this how it's so funny how
like the animation does not make sense
as far as oh yeah as far as this feet
just not matching up with like how fast
he's moving it's like adorable he's
having fun with it yeah I'm gonna walk
like this I know you can do something
here right oh yeah yes 'banahna me bring
bring out my sniper rifle there's a
second guy too
there is
now if you probably hit the wall with an
arrow that first guy will be distracted
and look trying to save my friend nice
call
where's the other guy and I was too late
oh you know two aisles on up you were
doing this trick guys did this a lot
watch huh no you saw nothing dude
okay so now you can probably get him
from behind if you're right in the boy
Safari step higher what's up here oh man
yeah I'm trying to learn how to sleep in
I don't know how to do it yeah I'm up at
like 5:30 every day dude your machine a
tired machine oh I know it's up here
the Gyges stash there is a time that
perfectly with each pickup okay I think
I can
so from here you've got a few options
there's that guy down there there's
another one patrolling over there there
is a guy in the hallway I believe as
well
oh all right get ready get ready to live
oh crap you know what unit Eddy's
guardian arrows on oh boy I thought
MERP I really thought I had I know
there's a drop there
miss good arts you know Peter I'm just
here for a more entertaining stream next
apparently I'm responsible so no big
guns
so lucky guys bananas Oh
oh yeah of course
regen all right this guy needs to get
out of here whoa you guys are close I'm
glad they're having to get though oh
this is my well that laughs no where are
you where's this don't worry he's right
there
this is going so well where is he hey
you know what I noticed though
Oh sir wait it doesn't look like their
health is regen now it is one guy wasn't
its progress ya ain't wasting anything
this is all part of the plan
[Music]
just try get a move stick in moves check
out that other Archer
[Music]
stuff can't like
[Music]
no I'm not trying to crouch man this is
tough where is he oh my god you know
I'll do I was like try to reason yep
you only freeze one at a time yeah I
just want to put the archer freeze
there is dirty dirty boy hit him I got
him right yeah you got it there goes my
ass oh I gotta you know I gotta focus on
a guy this time oh it's no problem
no problem at all those guys just don't
get faced you know with like stronger
can't faze them you can't that's the
problem that's the real problem
yeah yeah we got this you've got half an
hour and you know what I think you can
do it in ten don't not yet all right I
got distracted nope
oh no he's trimmer me
[Music]
that is not the stream we are not done
yet there you go I need to hear that
sweet music
you can technically go that way after
that little door that was on your right
yeah these manners though these are
clutch man these are like these and
durians I feel like I like some of the
best stuff like farm all right let's try
this party guy all right easy does a
camper you have Nonna's there I would I
would lower that thing and kill him oh
good god don't worry about the marchers
man and there's no way so is there no
way to proceed here even though they've
caught you like you can't go into the
far room and open the wall for sure I
got this for sure by the way I forgot I
had this
that's pretty good
[Music]
ports 2410 is wondering about the Master
Sword three sets of trials with multiple
levels in each for each set that you
complete it goes up in rating by 10
points so after the first set is at 40
and in 1516 people are telling us to use
bombs bombs are not strong enough to
kill these dudes not a massive node
I can do this oh there he is
[Music]
damnit
move move move all right
[Music]
I don't think I can like move away too
far I'll still warp out right like [ __ ]
let me let me see if I can sneak I'm
gonna shot put on my seeing goggles so I
can see all right how pissed you gonna
be if I do this in one shot
dammit why do I have sure
ice weapons apologize for swearing I
don't
I didn't forget what the button to throw
is is not a good start
you got it move it out further you can't
what do you can't that you could think
nieces robbed the hell do I throw
bananas a kid you don't throw bananas
you drop them
Rob hates this so much because he really
wants to try it again and right his
wrongs
damnit
kaneki just heard you you gotta come up
you just hitting out better hurry if you
jump jump jump oh oh oh man this
[ __ ] if I got to see the prompts
whatever whatever
Rob's Rob's not really happy where he
doesn't knows I'm gonna try again dang
it I do have a nice rod that's I don't
know why the controls are feeling weird
I think it's because there's pressure
involved it's fat and I don't know
I think the controller layout is like
different in some ways right like it's
it's the a and B I feel like it's like
swapped swept clamp
the guy from Lincoln Park died Abraham
Lincoln people die everyday it's a shame
if you're just joining us we are trying
to be you need to clean high down on
master mode that's what I'm super well
all right
Yoshii says he'll come back in four
hours
he's deaf and his left here dude yes
that's gonna be what guys feet [ __ ]
this guy is this down the wall literally
my gay did the last time do it on the
ground like close to his feet yeah this
is dudes problem shoot a banana kind of
like how that work that but it helps me
not maybe it's just the weird left side
of it that's odd
oh he won't even know there you go
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know someone in the clan gets fired
who's in charge of putting those on the
lock all right I say you did I got this
I say you just avoid them or like take
out a couple like you don't have to kill
them all since what are you a
sympathizer hey man here give me tips oh
no you can give me tips I'm just saying
I thought we hear that you get clean I
thought we want them dead
well apparently they never die they just
warp so we got one there we got one the
door there's a third guy back there a
guy near the door I think
there is a secret passageway behind you
see you finally oh there's a
[Music]
if you put bananas
guys can see there's no point all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right okay all right
that's it big guns coming out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
strike child is saying can't you just
climb around I don't know if we have
enough stamina to climb around maybe we
do maybe but aren't there some parts of
the wall that you can't climb on which
actually makes that more of a challenge
you can like walk
let's kill this guy I bet that's been at
least going somewhat well we can do this
part really well
[Music]
göran
[Music]
it might even be worth shooting out that
tapestry I don't know if that'll
distract him
what tapestry so on the back wall with
those white tapestries one of them
reveals a hole that you can go into it
takes you into a back room okay yeah
like right now I can show you that I
don't know if the I don't know if the
fire would alert them or what sort of
shot
I'll ER
yeah someone saying use fire arrows that
that might be the way to make that
happen
I would definitely take get this guy but
just be faster about it because I I
didn't know if he was gonna come at me
so by the time he turned around I didn't
have enough ground to cover before that
guy caught me okay it's working
I know you see it
come on hey maybe he's got to put it
right there
get your badass should I die or should I
just try to you Gmail we know not to
kill them we're not trying to I mean
well we can't we have to kill one of
them at least the man sorry let me to
yell at you Rob what do you think I
would just restart can you run through
the door run back there and see me this
month ago two habits no ex lock right
right
[Music]
yeah I worked out this is the definition
of insanity all right all right okay
okay you do it whoo Simmons oh we don't
have you know we can keep going you have
to stop at me thing I didn't realize too
is when I drop those bananas he would
have gone the second banana and I he
wouldn't see me
you know I mean yeah but that's that's
the way I felt to like I felt like by
the time he noticed me it was like wait
a minute
he was already abstracted on my last run
boy oh boy well thank you for sticking
with us chat we are going to beat Master
Kota I know it I am worried about it
just gonna take our time be patient
strike when the banana is hot does it
work yeah what do you think shy I don't
know sorry ignore these dudes well first
of all you don't even have to kill this
guy you can just get out of here
depends if you want the stuff yeah
someone says burn the tapestry and fly
through it I feel like if you fly
through it that might get you caught as
well maybe if you just maybe if you
timed it right sure this thing looks
like burned sorry oh yeah
firing it to the ground oh yeah I
remember doing this and they didn't give
a [ __ ] it's just kind of like oh yeah
but I don't think I don't know if that
gets you into the very back room but it
might put you in position to just
distract the one guard that matters how
do you mean again you have to get in
there to see it I'm talking about don't
fly sneak over there I think you'd be
fly you're gonna get caught
wreck this back it's up to you
CES we don't got no ancient arrows
unfortunately because playing on master
mode I'm getting at that point is
time-consuming and difficult um I'm
gonna go do my laundry some of this does
uh does that kill him in one hit
obviously I guess yeah easy peasy lemon
squeezy
okay so then over here when he's when
his backs turned just do it yeah yeah
when he's not facing you
obviously I feel like
[Music]
yeah I know about those tapestries as
well is pretty cool it's interesting to
write because in the first part of this
whole hideout it's like teaching you hey
look at these tapestries you can burn
them so then if you look got a gold repo
no man no chef its what are you doing
alright drop but you're gonna watch out
for that spikes okay so from up here you
want to distract that guy and get into
the door behind him and then you should
be in the clear so you need to throw a
banana and then gently make your way
into Z door
okay do they do they take longer to eat
more bananas they do yeah [ __ ] you learn
something new every day all right should
I do that do it man
[Music]
gently gently gently gently you did it
you frickin did it time just a normal
stream I know this part is Magnus is
robbed we ain't got time for this [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah can't even do this right all right
oh my god we did it here we go what a
minute left to take down goo goo all
right cool now you can turn up cuz I
wanna hear my favorite song in the whole
game down down down josh is still
watching I don't believe he is there's
no way yeah that's a Josh bot I'm pretty
sure josh bot josh is coming by later
today to lose at rocket League oh man
this boss is so freakin awesome super
tough
[Music]
suits been in bananas day and night I
[Music]
said him I'm overthinking it and you can
use stasis on this thing oh yeah let's
speed this up
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Syrian it is definitely a cute boss
hello
what's so charming oh yeah this one is
nice right
[Music]
yay despite all of our troubles we did
it the boss only three minutes late the
boss was before it hey we filled our
time man
dude we filled it I want a backstory on
this guy
[Music]
the localization like this the writing
is really awesome like serious moves
like he's got he's right about that they
definitely do track you all right all
right wait wait for it wait for it I'm
not waiting for
just that that stream cool congrats bud
thank you Peter for the support thank
you guys for watching thank you guys for
watching so you can find me on twitter
@pcc one
if I rob at simply Rob handler II Robert
Robert and Lori hmm sorry shoot us your
ideas if you have anything that you'd
like to see us do in master mode it can
be serious it can be not so serious we
just want to play and we like having you
guys around so thank you again stay
tuned for next week same time 11:00 a.m.
Thursdays on GameSpot tuning everyday at
11 a.m. for one stream or another this
has been fun
have a great weekend bye y'all